Hi.
My name is Jenna Hong,
and I am a senior
at MIT studying brain and
cognitive sciences and computer
science and engineering.
And my project is about
enhancing human memory
using augmented reality.
I'm really interested
in reverse engineering
the science of intelligence
to better understand
abstract concepts such
as causal and moral
reasoning and intuitive
psychology and common sense
understanding,
which are all things
that we use to better digest
and process the world around us.
Here, at the Genesis
Group and CSAIL,
we believe that
human intelligence
is unique in our
natural capabilities
to tell and understand stories.
I think it's really
interesting to study
how memory and learning
play a key role in this very
human storytelling.
And so I based my research off
of various neuroscience studies
at MIT that elucidate how
memory works in patients
of Alzheimer's disease.
So forms of dementia take the
ability to access and retrieve
memories away, but we can
still encode and store them
in the brain just fine.
And so I study the
moment where computers
can help model and augment
our very natural learning
processes.
I do my research in the Media
Lab in the Fluid Interfaces
group, where we're
working on building
a multi-modal augmented
reality system
that digitalizes something
called the memory palace, which
actually dates back to
ancient Greek philosophy.
The memory palace
leverages imagination.
By visualizing a
space or a location
that you know very well and
using mental images or visuals
and associating them on
particular points on the path,
you can better consolidate
these memories in your brain
just by re-walking the path
mentally or physically.
As it turns out, spatial
navigation and episodic memory
both rely on the same area of
your brain, the hippocampus,
and so I use audio-visual
sensory cues to trigger
neural firing in the hippocampus
to better consolidate
these memories through space.
And the results have
been really promising.
Over the past year,
I've been carrying out
a series of human
behavioral experiments,
and it shows that the paradigm
which I call memory lane
shows significant
improvement in retention
in both short-term memory
and long-term memory.
By showing that sensory
cues can actually
help us encode memories
in our brain better,
we show that artificial
intelligence can
help us both understand
human cognition
but also unlock
further innovations
in assistive mixed reality.
And so I hope that
this interface
can serve as a good first
step in empowering people
to overcome learning barriers
and memory impairments.